So with the hammer tube is is that long cylinder right the hammer tube is the long cylinder
You're don't you even know if you have the hammer tube right on your skin the bulb really isn't right on your skin
Because the bulb is inside the plastic sheety
Okay, so it doesn't make a difference doesn't make a difference to have it on your bare skin or versus through a pair of pajamas
I think the closer it is the less things it has to go through the more penetration you're gonna get so
For most people put it right on your pajamas is just fine
But if you want even greater penetration then put it underneath your pajamas
Is there a difference?
Is there a difference? I don't know isn't measurable no because we can't stick a meter inside your stomach to see the difference
But I think yes, I think that is a factor now I
I got a true rife is coming out with some updates that I was gonna say something but I can't
Because I forgot he promised me not to say anything yet, but I get a there are coming up with some updates that are gonna come out in February
So that's gonna be exciting
Yeah
Dr. Conner's including that the hammer ball with the crystal kind of light light
So the crystal tube is another choice with the hammer tube that he came out with about a
Couple years ago and he sent one to me to test. Well, how do you test it if it's better or not?
There's just no way to know so
You know, we haven't we haven't really used that one. It's it's it's more expensive and I just don't know that it's any better
So I just you know, we haven't we haven't done that